all right ryan kerrigan had some time
off between teams he became a free agent
back in the middle of march with
everyone else nothing happened nothing
happened nothing happened and then it
happened yesterday before the show he
posted on instagram a farewell to
washington which made people say well
where is he going we found out a couple
hours later he's going to the
philadelphia eagles staying in the
division uh oh
now hey look the eagles
are in the midst of an obvious i don't
know what it is i don't know if it's a
rebuild it's just this strange on the
fly yeah shedding of players and trying
to figure it out but he stays in the
division
hey look i don't i don't know how strong
the demand was for his services i saw a
report that the steelers and bengals
wanted him but it all comes down in many
cases to how much you're going to get
paid and you know maybe the eagles made
the best offer but kerrigan the all-time
sac leader in washington football team
history now makes the move
in the division from washington to
philadelphia that was kind of a surprise
yesterday because he'd been out there
he'd been available for so long but we
see that after the draft there are teams
that still have needs there are veteran
players out there and some of them end
up getting their jobs at that point yeah
after teams address or don't address
their needs in the draft veteran guy you
know probably not being looked at to be
a starter a guy that you just want in
the rotation to play some you know some
good snaps in every football game he's
gonna be choosy about where he goes
because of the point he's out of his
career wants to go somewhere where he
knows he's gonna play and of course the
money and all that stuff too so yeah
you're right that's not surprising
definitely not and i didn't expect them
back with the washington football team i
mean come on the washington football
team that front four they got one her
you know hercules after another there
kerrigan though a legend really i mean
not a hall of fame football player but
an nfl legend as far as i'm concerned
certainly a legend and a ring of honor
type of guy for the washington football
team and i think there's a real need for
his services on the eagles the eagles
are a team right now i think like you
said it is a rebuild it's a rebuild they
can call whatever they want they're
tearing it down and gonna build it back
up here and this guy good culture gonna
add some good you know
minutes on the on the defensive end
rushing the passer and be part of that
rotation
and they love that rotation when they
won the super bowl in 2017 i think they
had eight guys that rotated in
constantly keeping him fresh keeping the
pressure on the offensive line which
usually only has five guys with a swing
guy so they get worn down later in the
game now kerrigan 16th overall pick in
2011 feels like he's been around forever
and it's a long time it's 10 years
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports